let's check out the final advice Moore
had for us on value propositions now
you'll notice he uses the term
positioning statement and that's totally
ok many people use the term positioning
statement in value proposition
interchangeably so you know you hear a
lot about positioning and marketing and
I think your first instinct is to think
about that's something I'm supposed to
do but the first way you want to think
about positioning is actually where you
fit in your customers head so in other
words the world or your customer base
only has a certain number of little
compartments to put things in and so the
first question is what compartment are
they putting you in and and so remember
in that positioning statement we were
talking about where we said our product
or service is a blank
so the first positioning is to make sure
you're in the right box you're gonna put
in the right aisle in the supermarket
and that seems obvious but sometimes
there are multiple boxes you could be in
so it's important to think about where
do I want to compete and what category
don't want to compete so the first thing
is then it's just get yourself into the
right category then the second thing is
the way customers actually understand
you is relative to your competitors in
other words that's how they understand
the category and that's how they're
gonna understand you and how you're
different than the rest of the people in
the category so it's important that you
cook that you assemble a set of
legitimate competitors that you have
respect for you don't want to be the
best of a bad best house in a bad
neighborhood you actually want to be the
best house or the right house in a good
neighborhood so you want to pick worthy
competitors that that for some
situations you would acknowledge they're
actually better at solving that problem
than I am so that's the but but together
we're all in the business of providing
this general type of service and then
the last piece of positioning so after
you've done the kitchen area category
after you've established what we call
the competitive set then the last piece
of positioning is okay now why are we
different or how are we different and
why does that matter
specifically to the value proposition
that the customer would be bringing to
this purchase so you're helping the
customer saying the question you want to
answer is you would want to call us when
and and the the
opposite to that answer is on the other
hand if it were more of this situation
you probably should call one of the
others